♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brained. Long the
master of fire, tools, and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Ajit] And so we humans ask ourselves,
"Who are we? What are we doing here? Where
did we come from? How did we get here? And
where are we going?"
Two of these questions are amenable
to direct scientific enquiry
and constitute the science of
Anthropogeny; explaining the origin of
humans. So, the center CARTA is run by
Rusty, Gage, Margret and myself, along
with Pascal Gagneux, with management by
Linda Nelson, community relations by
Ingrid, computer systems by Kate and
programs run by Jesse.
Anthropogeny, of course, pursues
most academic disciplines so we involve
everybody across the mesa and across the
world in our activities. And our goal is
to use all rational and ethical approaches
to seek all verifiable facts from all
relevant disciplines to explore and
explain the origins of the human
phenomenon, while minimizing complex
organizations, structures, and hierarchies
and avoiding unnecessary paperwork and
bureaucracy.
In the process, we try to raise awareness
and understanding of the study of human
origins within the academic community and
the public at large. Special thanks to our
major sponsor, the Mathers Charitable
Foundation, Jim Handelman executive
director, and thanks to all of our
individual supporters, many of whom are in
the audience. This really means a lot to
us to get your support which helps us to
continue these programs. Special thanks to
Mr. John Armstrong who is providing the
closed captioning for the video recording
to the symposium, which by the way are
being seen live across the world right
now, and will eventually come on UCTV and
the websites later. Special thanks to
UCTV, Rich, Matt, Marcy, and Jacob, and to
the Salk Service's Kent and Neil running
things in the back there. So I'll close
this introduction with a rhetorical
question. "Which is the single organ
system that is most different between
humans and chimpanzees?" And the answer is
in this symposium.
With that Ill hand over to Nina Jablonski.
♪ [music] ♪